[Musique]
alors un jour un ami m'a dit si tu
rentres dans une pièce en parlant plus
fort que les autres
c'est toi qu'on écoutera moi j'ai
toujours bien pris soin de ne pas suivre
ce conseil et de pas rentrer dans les
pièces en parlant plus fort que les
autres parce que d'une part je suis trop
timide
d'autre part je pense pas avoir plus de
choses à dire que qui que ce soit
d'autre
du coup voilà c'est quelque chose que je
fais pas si tu rentres dans une pièce en
disant que c'est toi le meilleur bas
quelque part les gens vont commencer par
se dire c'est peut-être bel et bien toi
le meilleur
après tout là on est face à un sophisme
pure et simple il ya aucun moyen de
confirmer ou d'infirmer l'information
donc c'est peut-être bel et bien ça moi
j'aime pas trop les sophistes j'aime pas
trop les politiciens et de manière
générale les gens qui parlent plus fort
que les autres continuent entre dans une
pièce du coup c'est rigolo pour moi
d'être là aujourd'hui parce que
forcément je suis amplifié et donc vous
m'entendez très bien donc je parle plus
fort que les autres mais je viens pas
vous dire que je suis le meilleur et je
vais tout au plus vous apporter quelques
généralités sur mon métier est placé
deux ou trois citations de circonstance
donc moi je bosse dans le milieu de
l'audiovisuel c'est un métier un milieu
où il vaut mieux parler plus fort que
les autres quand on rentre dans une
pièce et dire qu'on est le meilleur
parce que sinon c'est difficile de
trouver du travail
du coup moi il a fallu que je trouve des
subterfuges pour passer outre ce
problème là et je me suis dit dans un
premier temps que la drogue et l'alcool
allait me permettre de désinhiber un peu
tout ça c'est vrai que ça marche plutôt
bien au début après c'est la santé qui
est en jeu
donc il faut être malin aussi et je me
suis ensuite dit que c'était peut-être
la culture qui serait une bonne porte
d'entrée pour avoir de quoi échanger
avec n'importe qui finalement mon idée
c'était plus je sais de choses plus
capable d'échanger avec n'importe qui
justement
mais ça aussi c'est un sophisme
parce que finalement être cultivé ça
fait pas de vous quelqu'un de plus
intelligent
ça fait juste de vous quelqu'un de plus
cultivé et il ya beaucoup de contres et
cultivé c'est vrai et je voulais pas
être cette personne qui s'est plaint de
choses mais qui comprend pas forcément
ce qu'elle sait du coup c'était pas non
plus à la solution l'audiovisuel c'est
aussi un milieu où
avant de faire un premier salaire faut
bosser pendant un paquet de temps des
fois des années parce que la loi du
marché c'est quand même le stage et si
vous n'avez pas un appartement pré
payées par les parents ou un nom de
famille qui permet d'enfoncer quelques
portes
bah c'est pas super évident moi j'ai ni
l'un ni l'autre
du coup il a fallu bomba que je
m'accroche évidemment et je pense pas
être stable particulièrement mais
néanmoins je continue de travailler dans
ce milieu là moi qui me faisait envie
depuis le départ et donc j'ai
l'impression que c'est déjà une victoire
en soi on va dire alors je suis né en
corse sans être corse
je suis un pin's août c'est une insulte
dans la bouche de certains corse
heureusement mon père a flirté avec la
mafia locale ce qui a permis à ma
famille d'avoir une sorte de légitimité
dans le village
mais ce qui m'a le plus porté c'est que
ma mère avant ma naissance elle vendait
des gouffres sur les plages et des
verbes alpin mais pour ma naissance à la
fabrique et de marionnettes et depuis ma
naissance ma mère fabrique des
marionnettes pour vivre avec succès et
en fait je voudrais rendre hommage parce
que en termes de développement personnel
et de deux des soeurs professionnel je
crois que j'ai jamais été confronté à
quelque chose d'aussi beau
et ça aurait été superbe ce soit elle
qui viennent vous parler aujourd'hui
plutôt que moi d'ailleurs je pense quand
j'étais en primaire alors ça c'est un
classique en ce que je veux dire on en
connaît tous un mail à ça c'était moi
quand j'étais en primaire c'était moi
quand on choisissait an dernier quand on
faisait les équipes de foot et en fait
ça fait mal quand en plus on aime bien
ça le foot
en tout cas c'était le cas à l'époque du
coup maintenant moi c'est un peu changé
forcément
et ça aurait pu dégénérer j'aurais pu
fabriquer des explosifs après tout on
était encore ce jeu de ça je suis resté
assis pendant des heures à regarder mes
camarades jouaient au foot et à me dire
tiens ben moi si j'avais été à sa place
j'aurais fait ci ou ça enfin voilà quoi
donc il en train de vous raconter mes
premières histoires j'étais peut-être en
train d'écrire mes premiers scénarios
quant au même âge à peu près quand
j'étais sous la douche je pissais dans
le siphon en me disant si tu touches pas
les bords du siphon marie jacqueline
c'était son prénom sera amoureuse de toi
donc c'était un peu tout remettre dans
les mains d'une entité supérieure ou
dans les mains de l'improbable parce que
évidemment que je touchais le siphon
quand je pissais et du coup je me suis
jamais déclarés auprès de marie
jacqueline est évidemment marie
jacqueline a certainement oublié jusqu'à
mon existence
cette timidité claquage avait gelé qui
était constellée d'acné en plus en tant
qu'à faire je les transformer en cancres
qui fout la merde au fond de la classe
et en seconde
la prof de français nous demandent
d'écrire un poème et elle passera
ensuite dans les rangs pour comparer ce
poème avec les oeuvres des grands
auteurs donc elle fait ce qu'elle a dit
et elle arrive à mon poème limon poèmes
moi j'avais vachement travailler en plus
sur le coup parce que je m'étais dit
pour une fois que la consigne me plaît
ce qui n'était pas super évident je vais
faire ça bien
elle lit mon poème elle me regarde dans
les yeux elle passe au suivant sans rien
dire alors moi j'ai jamais trop su si
cela voulait dire que ce que j'écrirai
c'était de la merde ou si elle est
faisait ça juste pour se venger
moi ça aurait pu dégénérer j'aurais pu
fabriquer des explosifs
heureusement on avait déjà quitté la
corse la question se posait depuis
au lieu de ça j'ai écrit ma toute
première nouvelle donc mon premier texte
littéraire je les écris à propos de cet
événement là voilà ce qui m'amène à ma
première généralités que je formule sous
forme de questions on va dire est-ce que
écrire ça peut soigner quoi que ce soit
et ben en fait je pense pas vraiment
c'est à dire que moi quand il ya un
problème en fait j'ai cette tendance à
essayer d'aller le chercher mais des
fois ça peut prendre un certain temps
quoi le problème ça peut mettre des
années ça peut mettre des mois ou des
semaines avant que j'aille vraiment le
chercher au moment où il entraîne dans
grainé et un moment donné on sert tu
sais que ça quand vous gagnez donc il
faut le sortir quoi moi
et du coup c'est ce moment là où je vais
écrire le problème en question je vais
mettre en avant quoi mais je vais
revenir un petit peu après à cet âge-là
bon les problèmes évolue la cne se
transforme en passeur yasi souvent dizy
droz
c'est à dire toujours des problèmes de
peau mais là qui sont plus liés au
stress et ça m'a permis d'écrire peu de
temps après un premier enfin premier
texte du coup un texte à ce propos c'est
l'histoire d'un type qui collectionne
ses déjections corporelle quelle qu'elle
soit pour pouvoir fabriquer un clone de
lui-même pour pouvoir à terme va se
faire un meilleur copain quoi peut-être
que ça parler un peu de moi de juger pas
ou peu de temps après quelques années
après j'ai tourné un clip avec des
rappeurs j'ai enlevé tous les sons du
clip j'ai gardé plus que les images et
j'en ai fait un court métrage avec le
son qui est devenu la voix off donc de
ce texte que j'ai donc appelé la passion
du christ
c'est un court métrage qui a eu un
succès un peu bizarre dans quelques dans
quelques festivals de courts métrages en
russie je blague même pas généralités
numéro 2 nous êtres humains on a cette
tendance blizzard a accepté les
relations des fastes pense que que ce
soit en couple malheureusement en amitié
ça se voit plus souvent et encore plus
dans le milieu professionnel
on est capable de
de côtoyer des gens qu'on aime vraiment
pas on est en pleine dissonance
cognitive
il ya un type que j'ai lu il n'y a pas
longtemps que s'appelle pacôme
thiellement qui disait on aime ne pas
aimer ce qu'on n'aime pas alors qu'il
faudrait apprendre à aimer ce qu'on aime
la formule je trouve qu'elle est bien
senti dans ce cas là moi du coup dans le
milieu de l'audiovisuel je me suis
retrouvé à bosser avec des labels dans
le milieu du clip des petits et des gros
et en fait je me suis rendu compte
qu'avec les gros labels
on n'avait pas du tout le même langage
eux ils avaient une véritable envie de
vendre un produit et je vous apprends
rien c'est qu'on ne sait pas tout neuf
évidemment mais vendre un produit contre
moi qui avais des petites velléités de
créateurs et qui pensaient que j'allais
faire des clips un peu artistique
ben en fait j'ai vite déchanté mais ça
c'était pas au début au début j'ai bossé
par chance sur des clips
alors c'est un univers qui me
correspondait pas du tout mais je
faisais des clips de rap et j'ai eu la
chance de travailler avec des gentils
rappeur à savoir qu'aujourd'hui autant
les gentils rappeur il squatte france
inter vous avez quelques noms en tête
mais il ya dix ans ils étaient pas il
n'avait pas du tout pignon sur rue et
moi ça a fait que j'ai pu poser un truc
là c'était de vue vous n'avez pas de
budget vous êtes obligé de me laisser
liberté artistique totale
j'ai dit les seins avec certains c'est
un marché avec moi ça m'a permis
finalement de
de développer une touche qui
m'appartenaient une une petite touche
quoi qui était la mienne on va dire à ce
moment là s'il sentait qu'elle soit
vraiment les miennes et de la déployer
auprès de ces groupes qui avait pas
d'argent donc je faisais tout ce que je
voulais c'était pratique et ça a fait
que j'ai continué à faire du clip avec
un paquet d'autres groupes on va dire
mais j'avais déjà ce truc là en
background
c'est à dire que je mettais pas conformé
à une esthétique à laquelle j'aurais dû
me conformer on va dire donc c'était
plutôt une force
puis j'ai fait un premier documentaire
sur une personnalité publique qui m'a
ouvert toutes les portes pour me laisser
faire un portrait bon on va dire
sensible de cette personne n'a quoi mais
arrivé au montage cette personne arrive
avec son staff pour justement faire une
sorte de censure en enlevant toutes les
parties les plus sensibles en question à
peu près sur la même période je fais un
autre documentaire cette fois sur un
chanteur qui s'est tellement livré en
interview face caméra que peu de temps
avant la diffusion il y avait un deal
avec une chaîne
peu avant la diffusion son manager m'a
appelé en me disant qu'ils viendraient
me péter la gueule personnellement si le
film était visible dont le film est pas
visible
je me suis débrouillé autrement avec la
chaîne mais bon voilà c'était ça m'a
fait un peu rire on va dire parce que
finalement le autant dans le clip
j'entends qu'on soit là pour produire un
produit à vendre une pub qui fait de la
pub et moi je veux bien me conformer à
ce truc là je trouve que ça fait sens
dans une certaine mesure dans le
documentaire par contre alors évidemment
personnalités publiques ou chanteurs
c'est des gens qui avaient déjà une
image d'eux-mêmes et eux ils avaient
cette nécessité de rebasculer cette
image qu'ils avaient déjà de même donc
moi je me suis un peu perdu là dedans en
fait à croire que j'avais la possibilité
de travailler en films hors films et duo
collaboration tout ça en fait c'était
pas aussi simple que ça c'est pas vrai
pour tous les documentaires que j'ai
fait évidemment mais bon là en
l'occurrence à se vérifier quoi autres
généralités la scène stein qui disait
c'est pas que c'est pas que je suis
intelligent c'est que je vide longtemps
avec les problèmes et je peux comparer
mes problèmes et sociale bien sûr mais
par contre je peux prendre cette formule
un peu pour moi c'est que à un moment
donné les problèmes que je peux avoir
j'ai cette tendance à les laisser
traîner et comme je disais tout à
l'heure jusqu'à la gangrène et va
arriver le jour où il s'agira vraiment
de les faire sortir et ça peut partir
d'un truc aussi bête que vous avez une
altercation dans la rue vous n'avez pas
les mots pour vous défendre et vous
allez passer le reste de la journée à
vous refaire l'altercation en vous
disant j'aurais dû dire si où j'aurais
dû dire ça quoi hélas de bd déjà vous
avez une histoire
vous avez un scénario moi c'est un truc
que j'ai tendance à laisser enfin voilà
ça m'arrive souvent de ce genre de
situation et du coup je vais je vais
apprendre à les utiliser
pareil à anglet de couple vous retrouvez
ensuite seule sous la douche et bain
vous refaites le match pour ainsi dire
quoi généralités numéro 4 du coude ou
viennent les idées en 400 ans avant
jésus christ et platon qui dit qu'est ce
qui dit platon il dit je me permettre de
faire ce que je disais je suis un cancre
donc je cherchais mes petites notes
il est même pas écrit en fait donc le
temps puis pour ça
d'autant pis dont platon disait savoir
c'est ce souvenir donc en quatre ans
avant jésus-christ platon dit savoir
c'est se souvenir ce qu'il a peut-être
voulu dire par là c'est que les idées
sont déjà là tout a déjà été dit il n'ya
plus qu'à se pencher en gros pour
piocher est à refaire siens ou sienne
unis des prêts existants puis en 1880 à
peu près on a à nietzsche qui dit
deviens qui tu es ou deviens ce que tu
es ça pose une autre problématique c'est
que personne n'est vraiment capable de
savoir qui il est et pour cause on a
tendance à se fabriquer en fonction de
la manière dont on est perçu
donc en fait on est le produit de ce qui
nous entoure
je pense qu'on est même tout simplement
le produit de ce qu'on voudrait que les
gens sous voie de nous on va dire donc
moi ce cas lui d'intéressant au final
dans tout ça c'est que mon écriture elle
se situe pile entre ces deux cd de
situation c'est que je vais les chercher
en moi ces problèmes donc je vais les
chercher quelque chose de hyper
subjectif hyper sincère et je vais les
rebasculer au plus grand nombre
et finalement il ya quelque chose on est
en plein discours dense cognitive aussi
c'est que on va essayer de rendre
quelque chose de très perso le plus
global plus possible et vu que à global
on a envie de plaire à tous enfin c'est
pas toujours vrai le premier mais
parfois il ya cette idée d'essayer de se
faire lire ou entendre par le plus grand
nombre
du coup on a tendance à trouver un juste
milieu entre tout ça et tout ça ce qui
fait que moi en parlant de dissonance
cognitive on peut dire que je suis
heureux d'être malheureux parce que
quand j'écris j'ai tout intérêt à être
dans un mauvais mood dans des
circonstances un peu un peu négative
parce que c'est là que ça sort on va
dire donc finalement c'est pas plus mal
que je sois malheureux donc ça me rend
heureux d'être malheureux c'est aussi
compté et il ya des amis à moi qui se
moque un peu en disant que je suis un
amoureux de l'amour et alors c'est vrai
que moi il ya beaucoup de mes histoires
en tout cas en termes de nouvelles qui
partent de d'histoire d'amour et donc
ils disent que je suis un amoureux de
l'amour et je suis un peu clients de
tomber amoureux d'un système plus que
d'une personne genre d'une situation
plus que d'une personne ce qui fait que
je vais me prendre de passion pour
quelqu'un à cause de ceux qui
l'entourent plus que de la personne en
tant que tel et déjà il ya cette espèce
de oued de gangrène qui se met en place
je sais d'avancé peu prophétisé en
général pourquoi est-ce que je ne sais
pas avec quelqu'un je sais que c'est à
cause de cette situation de ce système
que à terme je le sais dès le début
c'est débile quoi luxueux à terme je
vais me séparer cette personne quoi mais
là soudainement baissé
ouais c'est la douleur qui frappe à la
porte et qui dit bon bah tu vois ton
sujet là tu peux raconter quelque chose
tu as quelque chose tu as quelque chose
à écrire
donc voilà c'est un peu ce qui me
correspond mois dans l'écriture que ce
soit en littérature mais que ce soit
aussi en audiovisuel est bon je suis un
peu de musique haussier ça s'y prêtent
aussi pas mal et donc en fait je
voudrais bien finir en disant que moi je
regrette qu'on nous refuse à ce point la
sensibilité
enfin les mêmes l'hypersensibilité on
attend de nous d'être joyeux d'être
enthousiaste on nous laisse pas la marge
pour être triste on n'a pas le droit de
pleurer dans la rue c'est super mal vu
donc en général bien quand on est triste
mais on a l'air hyper sérieux et pour
moi être hyper sérieux c'est anti
romanesque quoi et je trouve ça hyper
triste d'être obligé de passer à côté de
cette de ce sentiment qui nous prend là
quasiment ça vient autant que la joie
quoi on ça devrait être équilibré et au
bout du compte des absents que ça
n'allait pas vraiment équilibré et je
pense que vu que l'art a tendance à
infuser les modes de pensée
si on laissait plus de sensibilité entre
est entre guillemets dans l'art et bien
les modes de pensée aurez la possibilité
d'avoir un peu plus de sensibilité et
vous pourrez peut-être récupérer ça dans
notre dans notre vie quotidienne et pour
finir finir finir à ceux qui continuent
de rentrer dans les pièces en parlant
plus fort que les autres et en disant
que c'est meilleur
moi je crois et j'espère qu'au bout du
compte c'est la sincérité qui qui
vaincra
parce que je crois que il ya que ça qui
compte et merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]